in Sydney thousands of people marked
Australia Day by taking part in a
protest
March jce calls to change the date of
the national day have been growing in
recent years demonstrators say it
celebrates colonization and the
dispossession of Aboriginal and torist
straight
Islanders in my opinion there should be
no Australia Day who celebrates the
genocide of any other people it should
be abolished this is not Australia Day
this is Invasion day to us
observed annually on January the 26th
Australia Day marks the anniversary of
the arrival of the British First Fleet
in Sydney Cove more than 200 years
ago this year's protests included a
sizable Palestinian representation with
some participants drawing comparisons
between the experiences of indigenous
Australians and
Palestinians I can clearly see this
country for what it is a brutal Colony
that seeks to maintain Supremacy racism
and
Injustice while some Australians still
celebrate their National Day others
particularly young people are
increasingly rejecting it earlier this
week statues of two Colonial figures in
Melbourne were
vandalized I think this day is about
recognizing that it's got Australia's
Got a dark history and we're here to
stand with our first nation's people the
debate around changing the date of
Australia Day Has garnered public
attention for years several communities
have moved their citizenship ceremonies
to another date and some retailers have
stopped selling Australia Day
merchandise Jessica Washington
alzero make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer